millions of Americans are filing for
unemployment amid the corona virus
pandemic many who have lost their jobs
have also lost health insurance in our
financial fallout series we've been
reporting on the economic impact of the
corona virus our consumer investigative
correspondent Anna Werner reports on the
health insurance options for the
unemployed this is the street they just
generally filled filled with people and
tourists the beach in Myrtle Beach South
Carolina is empty as is the hotel where
Donna Zweig used to work as food and
beverage manager until last month they
very kindly said that you know they're
going to have to let me go because they
just don't have the business they're
gonna not be able to open up the
restaurant so I moved here last June
from New Jersey and took on two jobs one
full-time at the hotel another part-time
at a university but she's now lost both
for how long isn't clear the uncertainty
the anxiety the mental pressure
financials it's beyond anything making
things worse her new health insurance
was supposed to kick in April 1st now
she's having to postpone a needed
medical procedure can't afford to pay
for that pocket is that something that
could impact your future health oh
definitely that's something Minnesota
doctor Hanna listen says she's seeing
daily the absence of our patients is
really striking and it's it's scary to
me some patients simply aren't showing
up she says because they no longer have
health insurance are you infuriated are
you sad all of those things at once it
is devastating I'm sad for my patients
I'm afraid for my patients and I'm angry
that we as a society created a
healthcare system that didn't quite
actually prioritize the health of our
patients insurance options for people
who are now out of work can be
complicated the Affordable Care Act
people who have lost jobs now to apply
through special enrollment to state
health care exchanges many can get
subsidies prices and plans vary some
laid-off workers qualify for Cobra
temporary coverage but it can be
expensive and if their incomes fall low
enough some people will be able to get
Medicaid but often only in certain
states health policy researcher dr.
Aaron Carroll we've done almost nothing
to try to ease the path or to make it
easy in fact it appears to be incredibly
difficult what's worse he says many
states appear to be overwhelmed it takes
a significant infrastructure to do all
of the checking and signing people up
and checking to see if they qualify for
subsidies and during all of that it's
not clear that right now in April a lot
of the exchanges especially at the
state-based level and at the federal
level I guess are actually staffed up
and prepared to do that to me that's
outrageous in a country as rich as ours
Senator Mark Warner and other Democrats
are now proposing a bill to reopen
enrollment for the Affordable Care Act
and expand Medicaid in states where it
hasn't yet happened so people don't put
off getting care somebody god forbid who
may be coming down with signs of the
virus should not be afraid of going to
the doctor because they can't afford to
pay in this kind of circumstance that
kind of reluctance to use the system
actually endangered all of us
Donna Zweig isn't sure any help will
come fast enough she's put the house
that was going to be her home in
retirement in Myrtle Beach up for sale
not gonna do me any good if I can't pay
for it now to see what your options
might be under the Affordable Care Act
you can go to healthcare.gov they'll ask
you a few questions and guide you
through to see what the options might be
in your state now if you have a story to
tell us about this or any other problem
you're having go to I send us an email
at health costs at CBS news.com Tony
yeah please do talk about a double
whammy and as you as you point out the
options for people who lost their health
insurance after losing their job it's
complicated it can be expensive doesn't
seem to be a good choice out there so
yes please write in folks
thank you very much